good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here i'm accompanied today
by deputy prime minister freeland and
minister jolie
we are here to speak about the
unacceptable actions by russia in
ukraine
canada strongly condemns president
putin's recognition of donetsk and
luhansk as so-called independent
strongly condemns president putin's
recognition of donetsk and luhansk as
so-called independent states
this recognition is a violation of
russia's obligations under international
law
and the charter of the united nations
canada also denounces russian military
actions including orders to move into
ukraine which is a clear incursion of
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
make no mistake
this is a further invasion of a
sovereign state
and it is completely unacceptable
president putin's speech yesterday was
inaccurate and contained dangerous
misinformation
russia's brazen provocations are a
threat to security and peace in the
world
i have been in constant contact with
president zielinski and our partners and
allies since this crisis began
last friday i had a call with president
biden prime minister johnson christopher
macron chancellor schultz and other
european leaders about the situation and
yesterday
i spoke again with president fonda lyon
of the european commission we are united
and steadfast in our support of ukraine
and have made clear that russian
aggression will result in severe
consequences
so today
in coordination with allies and
like-minded partners canada is
announcing a first round of economic
sanctions
we will ban canadians from all financial
dealings with the so-called independent
states of luhansk and donetsk
we will sanction members of the russian
parliament who voted for the illegal
decision to recognize these so-called
republics
we will ban canadians from engaging in
purchases of russian sovereign debt
and we will apply additional sanctions
on two state-backed russian banks and
prevent any financial dealings with them
these sanctions
are a major step and target those
responsible for violating the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
and they will remain in place until the
territorial integrity of ukraine
is restored
today in coordination with allies and
like-minded partners canada is
announcing a first round of economic
sanctions
from all financial dealings
with the so-called independent states
and donetsk
of russian sovereignty
and we will apply additional sanctions
on two state banks
russian banks and prevent any financial
dealings
with them
these sanctions
is restored it is not too late
for russia to seek a diplomatic
resolution and re-establish a pathway to
peace
but it is also clear that russian
actions violate international law
and threaten international peace and
security
so today
i am also authorizing a deployment of up
to 460 members of the canadian armed
forces
to operation reassurance
this involves more troops to latvia as
well as the deployment of an additional
frigate and maritime patrol aircraft
we're doing this to reinforce our
commitment to nato and promote peace and
security in europe
we're also stepping up our support for
nato
canada has pledged significant
additional medical
aircraft naval and land capabilities to
the nato response force
this is something that nato requested
from members
and will bolster our support of partners
and allies
minister anand will provide more details
in a moment
to all the members of the armed forces
canadian armed forces in latvia thank
you for your thank you wonderful works
you continue to eat
embody strengthen canadian values
i would also like to address canadians
who are presently in ukraine absolutely
your safety and your completely inquiry
your safety and security are a top
priority
consular services are available in
levive and you can reach out to global
affairs emergency watch and response
center to get support
their email is
sos at international.gc.ca
and phone or messaging numbers are
available online
and to the ukrainian canadian community
here at home
i know the situation
is deeply concerning
your community has made significant
contributions to building canada and we
will stand with you every step of the
way
earlier today i spoke with the president
of the canadian ukrainian congress and
reaffirmed canada's resolute and ongoing
support
of ukraine
the past years and weeks
canada has supplied very significant
resources to help ukraine defend itself
since 2015.
framework of operation unifiers
members of the canadian armed forces
were there
of some 620 million dollars
and supplied equipment that is now in
the hands of the ukrainian
canada will continue to be there
to support ukraine and its people
flagrant disregard for the independence
of a sovereign nation is a serious
threat to security and stability in the
region
and around the world
canada and our allies
will defend democracy we are taking
these actions today to stand against
authoritarianism
the people of ukraine
like all people must be free to
determine their own future we will
continue working with our international
partners to safeguard ukraine's
territorial integrity and prevent
further russian aggression
i'm happy now to turn it over to deputy
prime minister freeland
thank you prime minister
let me begin
by unequivocally condemning russia's
further invasion of ukraine
russia's actions are a violation of
international law
and of the rules-based international
this is
this is an attempt
to replace that rules-based
international order with a world in
which might makes right
where the great powers have the
authority to redraw the borders
dictate the foreign policies
and control the governments of sovereign
democracies whose only fault is that
they are smaller
and that their militaries are not as
powerful
history tells us that we cannot stand by
as great power attempts to redraw
borders and conquer its neighbors
and today is a test of our resolve
that is why canada has a clear and
present stake in this conflict
today's actions are only the first step
the measures that canada and our allies
have been preparing
will be sustained
and they will bite
the economic costs to russia will be
severe
but let me also be very clear
our quarrel is not with the russian
people
it is with president vladimir putin
and those around him
who are making the choice to threaten a
sovereign democracy
with subjugation
and it is not too late
for russia to pull back
that would be the right choice for the
people of russia
and for the world
but if russia does not pull back
it will be met with a firm united and
sustained response from canada and our
allies
the world's autocrats are watching today
to see if our alliance of democracies
has the will
and the capacity to stand up for the
rules-based international order canada
and our allies are resolute in our
defense of that order
and of freedom
human rights and democracy around the
world
[Music]
and democracy we know that in standing
up for themselves
the people of ukraine are standing up
for democracy
and international law
and so
we stand with them
thank you very much
i will give the floor now to my
colleague minister jolie
today and every day canada stands with
ukraine and its people we strongly
condemn president putin's recognition of
donetsk and luhangs as independent
territory and his decision to send
troops across the border
this constitutes a clear violation of
the minsk agreements
the u.n charter and the world order that
has protected global security for
decades
canada health found this order and we
have a role to play in its defense
we are also alarmed by the record direct
we're also alarmed by the rhetoric used
by president putin and his revisionist
understanding of ukraine's history and
reality
ukraine is a sovereign country and
president putin has no right to
unilaterally deny its right to exist
very strongly
the recognition
we are at the most dangerous moment for
world stability in a generation
russia's actions represent a direct
threat to the peace and security of
ukraine and the world
we have worked extremely hard to prevent
this escalation through diplomacy and
deterrence but just as russia has
prepared for this day
so have we
canada partners have been clear
the actions of the russian regime will
be met with severe consequences
these reckless and dangerous acts that
will endanger the lives of innocent
citizens will not go unpunished
let us be clear the invasion has started
our response begins today and should
russia escalate so will the cost imposed
by canada and its allies
will be very clear
sanctions package targeting first those
responsible for this illegal decision
and second russian banks
i would like to elaborate on our
sanctioning of
pillars of the russian financial system
which includes russia's central bank
russia's national wealth fund and
russia's ministry of defense
and of course their ability to continue
to fund this crisis
we know that russia has been building
its war chest
but these reserves will not last forever
as the economic pressure mounts from the
sanctions imposed by canada and its
allies
russia will need to seek new funding by
leveraging their sovereign debt
we will make it illegal for canadians to
join in that effort both directly and
indirectly
without a way to recover these costs the
russian economy will be severely
impacted
let me reiterate today's measures are
just the beginning
as we have said should russia further
invade ukraine it will be met with
severe coordinated economic sanctions
and increasing pressure if they refuse
to change course
canada's response is ready we are
prepared to target even more of russia's
financial sector and oligarchs and we're
ready to make significant announcements
related to canadian exports to russia
jose valentino
i
as well i've had the chance to talk to
the g7 ministers of foreign affairs this
morning i spoke to my john counterpart
just this afternoon we commend germany's
decision to suspend the certification of
north stream 2.
this has been our top priority since the
beginning and we've been resolute in our
efforts to reach a diplomatic solution
russia is responsible for this crisis a
crisis they fabricated through
disinformation and manipulation
let me also
be clear to canadians who are in ukraine
please
leave the country
i want to conclude by saying this
important message the international
community will continue to call on
russia to reserve to reverse course
which rides forces and choose diplomacy
we'll continue our tireless efforts to
achieve a peaceful outcome to this
crisis for the people of ukraine
the door of diplomacy is always open but
the window to do so before innocent
lives are put at risk is closing
thank you
i now pass the floor to my colleague any
dana
good afternoon bon appetit
i'm very happy to be here today
foreign
the alliance that has underpinned the
rules-based international order that has
kept us safe
since the end of world war ii
is being tested
much to mr putin's dismay however
nato is more unified than ever before
i've just finished a productive meeting
of nato defense ministers in belgium
and additional meetings at the munich
security conference
where i met with partners and allies
from across the alliance
and i witnessed
and felt
this resolve
i can say without hesitation
that our alliance shares a common
commitment to defending the rules-based
international order
during my time in europe
i heard over
and over again
that our allies want more of what canada
has to offer
and that is exactly what we are
providing today
we are announcing the authorization
of up to
460
additional canadian armed forces
personnel
under operation reassurance
this includes a significant bolstering
of canada's presence in latvia
where we lead
nato's enhanced forward presence battle
group
with 540 personnel at the current time
we will deploy an artillery battery of
up to
120 personnel in the coming weeks
brussels i met the ministers of defense
countries that are contributing to this
group
and which represents a third
is also announcing the deployment of an
additional frigate
hmcs halifax under a nato flag
to complement canada's current
contribution to nato's standing maritime
group two
we will also provide a maritime patrol
aircraft to bolster nato forces in the
euro-atlantic area
today i can also confirm that canada has
made a second delivery of lethal aid to
ukraine and we will continue to support
our ukrainian partners as they defend
their sovereignty
onset
christian
inside our nato allies
in defense of
transatlantic security
at this important time
merci beaucoup
thank you
thank you minister anand we will be
taking 20 minutes of questions starting
with reporters in the room one question
one follow-up vermin question
canada
will this make a difference
yes
perhaps
we stand together
throughout the world and what he has
done
can cost
very much very high
do you think that there is a possibility
there is always a possibility for a
diplomatic solutions
and that is to always defend democracies
rules-based democracies hi prime
minister tom harry cbc
vladimir putin has clearly taken
sanctions into account in his
calculations on ukraine so i'm wondering
what makes you think
any of this will be effective and if
it's not what more can canada and its
allies do
we know
that the impact of these decisions that
canada is making but also that our
allies are making are going to have real
real
feelings real
impacts on
the russian people and on the russian
economy
highlighting for example germany's
suspension of nordstrom 2
which was going to be a significant
source of revenue for the russian state
and russian federation
these are things that are going to make
a significant difference uh and
as
uh deputy administ deputy prime minister
freeland said um
our
issue is not with the russian people
our issue is with vladimir putin and his
decision
to unilaterally violate the rule of law
the international rules based order and
the sovereignty of the independent
nation of ukraine
you say that your your quarrel is not
with the russian people but i'm
wondering what the goal of these
sanctions is then is it to turn
putin's inner circle against them is it
to turn the russian people against them
and you noted that you're sending more
lethal aid are you trying to make this
as costly to russia as possible not just
in money but in casualties
i think
as we see a rise of authoritarianism
around the world as we see
challenges increasingly to democracies
to democratic principles
we need to all stand strong in defense
of those values and principles
and
if putin thinks
it is in his interest
to invade another sovereign country we
have to demonstrate to him that it is
not in his interest that he will not
come through this better or stronger
that this is harming russia and quite
frankly
to see the impact
uh
on ukrainian families to see
the fear to see and
to hopefully not see
the violence that could be coming in the
coming days as russian troops
further invade ukraine um
that will be costly not just in terms of
financial impacts
but in terms of
lost lives
in terms of lost credibility for
vladimir putin
and loss of stature for russia that has
shown that it is completely willing to
ignore the principles and values of the
united nations that has kept
our world remarkably peaceful for over
70 years
next question
mia rabson from the canadian press there
were some who'd been asking for
additional troops for for quite a while
before today as a deterrence measure why
did we wait until now to do this
we continue
to be strong contributors to nato we
continue to lead the enhanced forward
presence in latvia
we continue
to be committed and engaged in many
operations like operation reassurance
today we're announcing that we are
willing to do even more i think one of
the things that we have seen
with
putin's demands
around ukraine and nato presence that
far from
seeing a reduction
of
western forces in eastern europe
vladimir putin has achieved the opposite
and countries like canada and all our
nato allies are looking at reinforcing
our presence in eastern europe to
demonstrate that these actions by russia
are absolutely unacceptable
you've said that you're prepared to do
more if uh if this doesn't work but what
are you looking for from russia to
decide that you're not going to up up
what we're doing
we are looking for russia to stand down
to cease its violation of ukrainian
sovereignty ukrainian
territorial integrity
to return to the diplomatic negotiation
tables instead of
tossing the minsk agreement out the
window as they
chose to invade a sovereign independent
nation
russia needs to stand down it needs to
understand
that
there are consequences for a country
that chooses
to use force
to violate fundamental precepts of
international law that has
kept our world remarkably stable
for many many decades
this is something
that the entire world needs to stand
together with and canada and its allies
will stand up not just for our friends
in ukraine
but for the values and principles
of democracy
mercy
the first question is from ryan to
national post please go ahead
yeah good afternoon sir uh i'm wondering
on the emergencies act the the streets
in ottawa are clear today
uh of protesters i'm wondering um
you know the the emergencies act talks
about an ongoing emergency
when do you feel that this emergency
will have ended and allow you to revoke
the act
as i said yesterday
this act was brought in
because of an emergency but it is
proportional it is
scalable it is time limited and specific
every day
we
receive
information and briefings and analyze
whether it continues to be needed
and we are looking to lift it as soon as
possible that decision will be made at
the appropriate moment
following up
yes i'm just wondering if you can be
more specific you know this is a huge
piece of federal
legislation
meant to be used lightly what is your
threshold for removing it if it's not
the clearing of of border blockades and
and the streets in ottawa uh that is
exactly what we are looking at every
single day as we analyze reports come in
from across the country as we uh hear
the
recommendations and
and operational issues faced by police
agencies across the country in
intelligence services
as i said many times
we do not want this emergencies act to
be in place
for a day longer than necessary and we
are looking very carefully every step of
the way
as to when it can be lifted it was
always
reasonable proportional
entirely subject to canada's charter of
rights and freedoms and specific and
time limited in its application
we continue to re-evaluate to see when
it will no longer be necessary
the next question
is
[Music]
[Music]
that was intended to
a unifier have left ukraine but i think
that the minister can deal with this
more directly
[Applause]
bonjour melanie
um
uh
uh
is
we're going to make our foods
my colleagues in europe i was there
i said to partners
to strengthen
lotto
is
um
of communications
is
[Music]
with respect to diplomacy i'm going to
give the minister of uh global affairs
the floor is um
um
is from stephen chase from the globe and
mail please go ahead
yes good afternoon uh question is about
our embassy staff and levi and
are they
still operating there and how long are
they going to operate there or have you
started removing them
we
a number of weeks ago started to scale
down our presence in
ukraine for protection of canadians and
canadian consular
services and families consular services
continue
including
a embassy staff in levive
but
those decisions will be made day by day
as to
how long our ambassador stays there and
the small staff she has around her but
i'll turn to
again minister foreign affairs for
further clarification on that
um thank you steve um so
there are
members of
global affairs canada and their head of
mission our ambassador is indeed in the
vive um they are also along other
countries including the uk and the u.s
which is also in aviv we decided to move
our operations from kiev to leve
a couple of days ago
and that was for security reasons but
the goal was to stay in ukraine as long
as possible we think it is important
that we be there to offer considerate
services and meanwhile our advice to
ukrainian canadians is clear
if you're in ukraine please leave now
thank you
following up
yeah the second question is about the
460 number and my question is how many
how much of this
this number will be going to
latvia and i assume the rest is
you're just counting the people on the
frigate and the people on the on the
plane which i assume was an aurora
hi steve let me lay it out for you an
artillery battery of about 120 people
that is
will be the first element to deploy in
30 days for approximately six weeks that
that uh congregation of people will be
drawn from bases across the country
the
large trash of the 460 is going to be
placed
and part of the hmcs halifax as you
suggested in your question that
will be deployed in march
towards the
last part of march
and finally the cp 140 maritime patrol
aircraft will
also have a contingent of that 460.
so you can see that we are dividing up
the contingent of 460 across these three
different items thank you
thank you all this is what ends today's
press conference is